willkommen zur aktuellen sitzung heute
geht es um das thema datenschutz
privatsphäre dass es ein sehr relevantes
thema ist wird sicherlich immer
relevanter werden in zukunft warum weil
die digitalisierung immer weiter einzug
hält in unsere gesamte lebenswelt so
dass man eigentlich von einer
digitalität und nicht mehr nur von einer
digitalisierung sprechen sollte ich habe
dazu auch einiges gesagt und machen noch
mal oben rechts den link zu dieser
sitzung hinein wo wir uns damit befasst
haben ja das thema datenschutz ist ganz
wichtig es ist jetzt nicht so neu dass
man denken sollte es kam erst ins spiel
als wir die internet technologie
entwickelt hatten datenschutz ist ein
ganz ganz altes thema warum weil es
unsere privatsphäre betrifft also
datenschutz und privatsphäre gehören
ganz eng zusammen und ich möchte jetzt
für die heutige sitzung einige
leitfragen präsentieren über die wir
dann auch im anschluss diskutieren
werden und die zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer auf youtube gerne auch unten
dann im kommentarbereich
stellung nehmen können die erste frage
wäre was bedeutet privatsphäre und
datenschutz aus philosophischer
perspektive
das ist ja die frage unseres seminars
wir wollen ja keine soziologe keine
informationstechnologische analyse
dieser ganzen neuen themen unternehmens
und eine genuin philosophischen wir
müssen uns fragen was bedeutet jetzt
privatsphäre und datenschutz aus
philosophischer perspektive dann wie
verändert sich
privatsphäre im zuge der digitalisierung
diese frage zielt darauf ab ob die
digitalisierung als technologie
datenschutz und privatsphäre verändert
gegenüber diesen form die wir schon
kennen von datenschutz und privatsphäre
oder anders gefragt ob sich daten und
informationen die unsere pension
betreffen durch die technologie des
internets zum beispiel
ändert
wird da neue formen
von
datenschutzproblemen gekommen meine
these ist ja aber wir müssen es noch
genau dann diskutieren was spricht für
die beibehaltung des prinzips der
privatheit was dagegen in zeiten des
internets es gibt eine große diskussion
darüber ob wir vielleicht nicht
angesichts dieser vernetzung die stadt
fällt im virtuellen raum die auch
notwendig zu sein scheint diese
vernetzung von uns auch uns von tagen ob
wir da nicht vielleicht dieses prinzip
des datenschutzes oder der privatheit
ganz über bord werfen sollen er gibt es
eine große diskussion da werde ich
nachher noch zwei titel dazu vorstellen
und dann auch eine ganz spannende frage
wie verhalten sich datenschutz und
autonomie zusammen autonomie also sowas
wie selbstbestimmung individuelle
freiheit freiheit der person das ist ein
sehr philosophische begriff ist
natürlich auch ein pädagogischer
sozialer begriff wir wollen aber aus
philosophischer perspektive heute
betrachten wir wollen ihm in ein
verhältnis setzen zum thema datenschutz
das sind die fragen die wir uns heute
vornehmen wollen und jetzt hatte ich
schon gesagt es gibt ein gibt natur hier
ein ziemlich grundlegendes werk wenn
auch eher aus soziologischer perspektive
aber dennoch sehr zu empfehlen titel
treiber sie im kontext technology policy
and integrity of social life von
hemmnissen baum dieses buch ist schon
circa zehn jahre alt wenn sie in den
titel schauen da geht es um die
unversehrtheit und integrität des
sozialen lebens und dieses titelbild
deutet schon an einer seite es gibt hier
vernetzungen von verschiedenen
knotenpunkten das könnten wir sein wenn
sie sich diese punkte anschauen diese
blauen oder roten bälle dann sehen sie
um die heroben ist noch mal so ein kreis
gelegt diesen kreis dem interpretiere
ich jetzt mal als diese schutz fairer
diese schutzraum der um uns herum
sich befindet aber auch mit anderen
schutzräumen in verbindung steht also
diese nahtstellen wir sind nicht direkt
als kugeln miteinander verbunden sind
wir haben da noch so eine privatsphäre
um uns herum um die steht einer spannung
auch immer wieder mit unserem bedürfnis
miteinander in bezug zu treten und
informationen auszutauschen
möchte hier ein zitat vorlesen aus
diesem buch information technology ist
konnte majors threat to
cable space surveillance massiv database
and lightning speed die studios schon
auf information security
information technologies
zinswende dominant konzerns massiv
databases auf government solutions
haus und lifestyle und computer konzerns
heft multiclient
extent es radikale transformation of
technology
and
distributed networking world wide web
mobile devices video audio and balance
survey jens global positioning
ubiquitous computing
social networks central networks
database auf kompakte information data
one and more ja was sie führt hier an
dass dieses problem der
datensicherheit des datenschutzes der
privatsphäre bereits sich länger
darstellt seit den 60er jahren sie
kennen alle diese bindung big brother is
watching you also die institution oder
diese größe vor der wir die daten
schützen müssen ist
in diesem text jetzt zu beginn auch der
staaten oder soziale institutionen der
start der alle informationen über uns
haben möchte vielleicht ja ist der staat
überhaupt eine person wie auch immer
also hier galt jetzt anfangs erst der
staat oder soziale institution als
gefahr größe die unsere daten
interessieren könnte und diese
institutionalisieren oder fokussierung
auf einzelne institutionen hat sich
durch die digitalisierung vor allem in
den letzten jahrzehnten gewandelt
hier ist jetzt nicht mehr nur der staat
sage ich jetzt mal diese gefahr die da
droht sondern es sind alle möglichen vor
allem auch ökonomische firmen global
player ich werde noch mal näher darauf
eingehen auch wenn sie dann die
aufzeichnung nachher sehen auf youtube
das betrifft mit diese frage wie sieht
es mit dem datenschutz aus wer bekommt
die daten welche daten überhaupt werden
hier gesendet alles hat sich für
kompliziert sie sagt jetzt hier
multipliziert in form art und ausmaß
und sie spricht hier auch von einer
prise wer jetzt also dieses pervasive
oder die sich überall aus denen von
nichts mehr halt machen das ist wirklich
eine
wichtige dimension der digitalisierung
in ihrer positiven wie auch in ihrer
negativen in sicht vor allem fällt es
natürlich auch wenn wir das internet
betrachten hier unten das internet ist
nicht mehr nur ein laues stendaler und
computer der irgendwo in einer großen
halle steht und vielleicht sogar während
fußballfeld groß ist wie das in den 50er
60er und 70ern vielleicht noch der fall
war sondern es betrifft alle
daten werden überall vernetzt auch mobil
unterwegs es gibt eigentlich gar kein
halt mehr vor den daten oder genauer
gesagt vor den datenaustausch also das
hat sie jetzt hier klar wo sehr gut
dargestellt dieses problem wie wir mit
daten umgehen das nimmt zu in dem gerade
in dem auch die technologie
zunehmend und unser ganzes leben durch
trinkt es ist eben mir noch einmal
wichtig zu betonen digitalisierung ist
nichts was bestimmte bereiche betrifft
sollen das alles tendenziell betreffen
kann ob sie alles schon betrifft ist
eine frage der zeit aber von ihrer
struktur her ist digitalisierung eine
technologie die eigentlich alles
betreffen kann und das macht sie
einerseits sehr leidvoll andererseits
aber auch sehr problematisch vor allem
aus ethischer sicht warum weil das was
sie betreffen kann eben auch uns
betrifft uns als individuen uns
hinsichtlich unserer information und
zwei privaten daten die wir eben
schützen wollen ja jetzt möchte ich noch
ein weiteres buch vorstellen was jetzt
so ein bisschen in anderen focus wirft
auch frische perspektive trifft auf
diese thematik des datenschutzes nämlich
verbund transparenz gesellschaft punkt
schule
hat dieses buch
kürzlich geschrieben und ich möchte hier
auch ein zitat vorlesen aus dieser
ankündigung des buches kaum ein anderes
schlagwort beherrscht den öffentlichen
diskurs so sehr wie die transparenz wird
vor allem im zusammenhang mit der
informationsfreiheit
emphatisch beschworen wer aber die
transparenz allein auf moralischer ebene
thematisiert und sie etwa auf fragen der
korruption reduziert verkennt ihre
tragweite mit transparenz ist ein system
statt zwang der die gesamten
gesellschaftlichen prozesse erfasst und
sie eine gravierende veränderung unter
wird das gesellschaftliche system setzt
heute alle seine prozesse an transparenz
zwang aus um sie zu operationalisieren
und zu beschleunigen
der imperativ der transparenz macht uns
außerdem zu sklaven der sichtbarkeit die
transparenz gesellschaft ist eine
pornographische ausgestellte
gesellschaft sie manifestiert sich
gleichzeitig eine kontroll gesellschaft
das internet als raum der freiheit er
war jetzt nicht als ein digitales
panoptikum
und das ist jetzt die beschreibung also
hans neue es geht den illusion und
gefahren nach diebe die paradigma der
transparenz verboten sind auch nicht
wichtige perspektive jetzt ihr aus den
soziologischen perspektive aber auch
philosophisch relevant das internet
scheint das ideal zu grunde zu legen
haben das prinzip wird alles geteilt
werden kann das ist der vorteil dieser
reibungslose vernetzung und wenn es mir
das konsequent zu ende denken könnte am
ende tatsächlich so etwas wie das ideal
oder auch die realität einer transparenz
gesellschaft heraus kommen und hier muss
man sicherlich ganz kritisch da sich
diese entwicklung anschauen möchte
zuletzt noch ein buch vorstellen was
diese transparenz idee noch weiter
entwickelt oder weiter radikalisiert
nämlich von christian heller post
privacy prima lieben ohne privatsphäre
der titel ist ganz wichtig post privacy
das heißt hier geht es um eine situation
nach der privatheit also hier wird eine
eine gesellschaft thematisiert an
soziologie
thematisiert die die privatsphäre eben
nicht mehr ernst nimmt sondern sie
gewissermaßen aufgehoben hat die also da
besucht einen schritt weiter zu gehen
das ist natürlich ein naheliegender
gedanke wenn im internet alle dinge
erteilt werden können
warum sollten wir dann nicht einfach
dieses prinzip der privatsphäre aufgeben
eine gewisse vorteile haben auch hier
möchte ich ein beschreibungstext
vorlesen zu diesem buch google street
view facebook und co privatsphäre als
persönlicher raum der sich sicher weiß
vor fremden blicken ist praktisch tot
schuld ist das internet datenschutz ist
ein kampf gegen windmühlen bestenfalls
ein hinauszögern des unausweichlichen
wichtiger ist die frage wie wir unser
leben ohne die sich erhalten der
privatsphäre lebenswert machen können es
gab früher zeiten ohne privatsphäre und
es wird wieder zeiten ohne privatsphäre
geben bei genauerem hinsehen wird klar
dass sie ohnehin nicht der lupenreine
wohltäter ist den datenschützer gerne
aus ihr machen ihre auflösung bringt
nicht nur aufgaben denen wir uns stellen
sondern chancen die wir ergreifen
sollten hierbei wird dieses buch helfen
durch aufzeigen neuer lebensführung
strategien und alter und neuer funkelte
hierfür also hier wird jetzt die these
vertreten es ist hoffnungslos in zeiten
des internets in zeiten der globalen
vernetzung überhaupt datenschutz
konsequent durchzusetzen wir sollten es
aufgeben und wir sollten lieber
versuchen eine lebensführung strategie
also lebensweltlich neue formen des
umgangs mit dieser post privacy zu
etablieren also praktisch uns darauf ein
zug einzurichten darin darin
einzurichten dass es dieses prinzip
geben kann
ja das ist natürlich auch
starke these über die wir auch im
anschluss treffen diskutieren können
jetzt möchte ich aber zurückkommt zum
eigentlichen thema nämlich der frage
nach privatheit oder privatsphäre als
eigentliche philosophischen probleme
was ist jetzt all das philosophische
problem des datenschutzes datenschutz
bedeutet dass bestimmte informationen
über eine person können auch mehrere
personen sein können auch kollektives
seien aber am ende denkt man hier schon
sehr vom individuum aus dass die
geschützt werden das heißt dass diese
person selbst entscheiden kann welche
informationen sie fand sich wann wo und
wen zugänglich macht welche information
wann wo wie zugänglich zu machen diese
entscheidungen hier ist selbst
entscheiden hat natürlich was mit
unserer autonomie mit unserer
selbstbestimmung zu tun und das ist
wieder ein ganz hohes gut nicht nur
philosophisch sondern eben auch
gesetzlich also mit dem begriff der
privatsphäre verbunden ist der begriff
der würde der person und ihre autonomie
privatheit ist subjektiv auch mit scham
verbunden
das ist die andere seite das kann man
philosophisch psychologisch sehr gut
untersuchen wer von sich daten
preisgegeben hat dir gerne nicht
preisgegeben hätte oder wem
eine ein datenleck droht das so dass die
eigenen informationen plötzlich frei
zugänglich im internet sind der oder die
wird sich schämen so war wahrscheinlich
das hängt immer natürlich davon ab was
für daten dass sie da wenn es aber sehr
private daten sind
irgendwie bilder aus dem letzten urlaub
oder sowas
wo man vielleicht auch ja dinge zeigt
die vielleicht nicht jeder zeigen soll
weil der person mit drauf sind wie auch
immer die einfach niemanden angehen der
wird sicherlich sich sehr unwohl fühlen
und kann dass er auf alle möglichen
weiteren dinge vertragen diese scham
wieder eventuell ins spiel kommen kann
das heißt in der privatheit haben wir
einen schutzraum uns herum den zu
überschreiten anderen nicht gestattet
ist und hier gibt es jetzt neben das
grundgesetz artikel 1 absatz 1 satz 1
die würde des menschen ist unantastbar
sie zu achten und zu schützen ist
verpflichtung aller staatlichen gewalt
also die würde des menschen muss
geachtet
jetzt werden und der schutz der würde
dann eben oder sollte eben muss auch
wenn sie wird des datenschutzes
verstanden werden
privatsphäre muss man jetzt auch sich
mal genauer anschauen als begriff als
philosophischen begriff privatsphäre
bezeichnen raum der intimität und
individualität in denen nicht ohne
schwerwiegende gründe von außen
eingedrungen werden darf ich sage nicht
ohne schwerwiegende gründe weil es
sicherlich situationen gibt wo eine
person auf richterlichen beschluss
praktisch einblick gewähren muss oder wo
sogar sich einblick gewährt wird wie zum
beispiel ein hausdurchsuchungsbefehl
vorliegt hat als die privatsphäre kann
ganz normal ganz offensichtlich erstmals
die eigenen vier wände angesehen werden
niemand darf sich unbefugt zutritt
verschaffen in mein zimmer und da
irgendwelche daten suchen das geht
niemanden was an das hat mit unserer
würde und autonomie zu tun das heißt die
verletzung der privatsphäre bedeutet
auch eine person zuvor objektivieren
stellen sich die situation vor jemand
dringt in ihre wohnung ein und
durchsuchten
alles wie fühlen sie sich in dieser
situation wenn irgendwelche
informationen
herausgelassen werden die ihn privat
erscheinen dann schämen sie sich unter
umständen sagen sie das geht niemanden
was an ich fühle mich nackt so das war
aber nur der prozess dass eine person
oder eine institution ihre daten
durchsucht ihre privatsphäre betritt
wird dazu führen dass sie sich wie ein
gegenstand behandelt fühlen dass sie
sich in ihrer autonomie beschränkt
werden sie werden zum gegenstand einer
äußeren macht und sie werden zum bloßen
objekt einer äußeren kontrolle erstens
nicht sehr angenehm und dieses gefühl
trügt nicht das ist ein großes
juristisches soziales psychologische und
eben auch philosophisches problem
und jetzt können wir uns die frage
stellen wie verändert sich die
privatsphäre wenn wir im internet
unterwegs sein meine these ist dass man
noch viel zu häufig das internet mit bei
der einem haus analysiert das internet
wird
analysiert wie viel physische wände oder
wie eine große eine große halle der wir
unterwegs sind und die wir selbst eine
kleine halle mitbringen oder indem wir
selbst unsere eigenen vier wände hinein
nehmen und sie sehen das ganze bild das
der tief also wir können in meinen augen
nicht mehr das internet wieso vier wände
verstehen im internet wird alles
durchlässiger und irgendwie auch anders
die autorin hemmnissen baum hatte
geschrieben es wird transformiert das
ist sicherlich richtig wir als
philosophin und philosophen müssen uns
jetzt fragen wie wird die daten
situation die privatsphäre wie wird die
transformiert wenn wir uns ins internet
begeben das setzt natürlich erst mal
voraus dass überhaupt uns klar darüber
werden müssen was das internet
eigentlich aus philosophischer sicht ist
es gibt hier ganz verschiedene
kandidatinnen kandidaten für die
bestimmung des internets das heißt es
hängt entschieden davon auch wie wir das
nicht verstehen wenn wir die frage nach
dem datenschutz und privatsphäre im
internet klären war das internet ist
kein begriff der eindeutig ist wir
müssen hier erst einmal arbeit lässt
vorarbeit leisten jetzt möchte ich auch
noch mal den datenschutz speziell als
philosophisches problem thematisieren
die privatsphäre hatten wir schon
thematisiert da war das wichtige dieser
raum und die würde
also daten können mehr oder weniger mit
ins privatsphäre zu tun haben nicht
jedes datum von uns
würde jetzt für uns zu privatsphäre
zählen es mag auch sein dass von uns
einige der meinung sind jesus datum
diese information gehört zu meiner
privatsphäre andere mögen der meinung
sein dieses datum gehört nicht zu meiner
privatsphäre ich gebe ihnen ganz
einfaches beispiel ihre adresse
gehört ihre adresse zu ihrer
privatsphäre oder nicht
es ist schwierig wenn man an das
klingelschild geht dann steht da ihren
namen drauf wahrscheinlich
vielleicht stehen sie noch im
telefonbuch vielleicht standen sie mal
im telefonbuch es gab zeiten wo sehr
viele menschen im telefonbuch für die
auf diesen großen und mit diesen großen
büchern an die ich mich noch erinnern
kann wo tausende und abertausende von
namen abgedruckt waren wo die darin
standen
das andere problem war dass es häufig
personen gab am selben ort die den
selben namen hatten dann wurde es schon
schwieriger konnte man immer sagen ja
gut ich steh da zwar drin aber es gibt
sehr viele die ähnlich heißen wie ich
und da falle ich nicht so auf unter
dieser großen anzahl
aber es gibt informationen die scheinen
sich dieser privatsphäre zu entziehen
das ist so vielleicht so etwas wie
adresse
anderer punkt ist wenn sie die straße
auf die straße treten dann werden sie
gesehen das heißt man sieht als
information die öffentlichkeit zieht wie
sie aussehen sie sieht andere dinge sie
weiß vielleicht nicht gleich wie sie
heißen sie haben ja ihre namen nicht auf
der stirn irgendwie so als qr code zum
glück noch nicht aber sobald man sich in
die öffentlichkeit begibt und das ist
ein wichtiger begriff der öffentlichkeit
werden sie nun notwendige reis oder
überhaupt öffentlich mit existieren zu
können gewisse daten nach außen hin
bewusst oder unbewusst kommunizieren
welche daten dass das ist nicht die
frage
und jetzt kann man hier unterscheiden
zwischen
metadaten metadaten sind
scheinbar äußerliche daten über daten
und der begriff des mitarbeiters ist
auch nicht klar definiert es auch ein
bisschen relativer begriff ein beispiel
wäre die uhrzeit zu der eine person
bestimmte daten von nicht bekannt
gegeben hat also das wäre ein metadaten
also dieses datum diese prinz die
private information von personal das ist
ein datum und das ist von der
privatsphäre problematisch dieses datum
oder nehmen wir mal ein beispiel auf
facebook posten sie ein urlaubsfoto
aus monaco
und dieses datum dieses datum wann sie
dieses bild gepostet haben das wäre zum
beispiel ein mittag hat dieses bild aus
monaco ist hingegen ein normales datum
könnte man so sagen jetzt kann man aber
natürlich sagen nein auch die uhrzeit
war nicht dieses urlaubs foto gepostet
habe das ist baulich so ohne weil ich
könnte das foto gepostet haben um 3 uhr
23 und der nacht da kann ich dann schon
bestimmte dinge rück schließt ja also es
so
oder so banal sind metadaten auch je
nach interesse können auch metadaten
rückschlüsse auf private daten einer
person geht zb tagesrhythmus
beziehungsstatus alter nationalität
beruf bildung einkommen politische
ausrichtung und je mehr wir künstliche
intelligenz in die praxis der daten
ordnung integrieren um so leichter fällt
ist aus metadaten wirkliche daten zu
generieren weil wir durch ganz komplexe
algorithmen aus diesen metadaten auch
andere daten errechnen können ja das
heißt diese differenzierung von datum
und meta datum ist irgendwie auch
problematisch also metadaten sind in
ihrer fülle und im verbund mit
künstlicher intelligenz sehr sehr
wertvoll das heißt jeder ökonomische
player wird versuchen nicht nur unsere
primären daten abzugreifen soll auch uns
gemeckert und vor allem eben die
metadaten beide sich am ende zu barer
münze machen lassen natürlich vor allem
aus finanziellem interesse wenn ich weiß
wie alt diese person ungefähr ist hat
das alte jetzt auch ganz wichtig wenn
ich weiß
das war komisch hinter gut hat sie hat
was für interessen sie verfolgt was ihre
suchanfragen sind und kann ich aus
diesen faktoren verbunden mit metadaten
hochinteressant profile erstellen
ökonomische profile die wiederum sich
für werbekunden ein dann kann ich dieser
person automatisch generierte
werbeanzeigen schalten die auf diese
person am besten zu treffen scheint so
dass die chance die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass diese person dann von diesen
werbetreibenden ein produkt kauft am
größten ist und so wird dann einen
finanziell gut aus also datenschutz
bedeutet aus philosophischer perspektive
dass wir vor der instrumentellen für
gegenständliche überwiegend
kommerziellen daten geschützt werden das
ist jetzt wieder ein philosophisches
problem wir neigen dazu im internet vor
allem aber grundsätzlich nieder form der
öffentlichkeit zu daten vergeben ständig
zu werden und zwar vor allem zu
kommerziellen darf im internet
interessiert aus kommerzieller sicht
nicht was unsere individuellen probleme
sind sofern sie nicht sich ökonomisch
nutzbar machen lassen das ist natürlich
auch eine reduktion ist wir werden
reduziert und unsere wird in unsere
individualität auf ökonomische
interessen
wenn wir zur daten für objektiviert
werden drohen wir äußeren kontroll und
überwachungsmechanismen zu unterliegen
wir wissen nicht was passiert mit diesen
informationen was geschieht mit uns und
das ist wiederum ein eingriff in unsere
autonomie und unsere würde
und diese für objektivierung die mit uns
häufig geschieht eben auch im internet
die erlaubt es personen aufgrund
bestimmter eigenschaften zu
diskriminieren das ist auch noch ein
ganz wichtiger punkt was der würde der
person natürlich auch widerspricht mehr
die da wo wir milliarden von daten
informationen auslesen und automatisch
auch bewerten können da liegt es nahe
wenn wir finanzielle interessen zu
grunde legen bestimmte person
hinsichtlich ganz willkürlicher faktoren
zuzuschreiben dass scheinbar die einen
kriterien mehr finanziellen gewinne
erhoffen lassen als andere das ist ein
riesenproblem die für gegenständliche
unserer individualität
jetzt gibt's natürlich dazu jede menge
juristischer mittel und grundrechte ist
möchte nunmehr die charta der
grundrechte der europäischen union hier
gibt es den artikel 8 schutz
personenbezogener daten möchte ich auch
mal vorliegen lesen jede person hat das
recht auf schutz der sie betreffenden
personenbezogenen daten es ging da schon
mal sehr gut
zweiter satz
diese daten dürfen nur nach treu und
glauben für festgelegte zwecke und mit
einwilligung der betroffenen person oder
auf einer sonstigen gesetzlich geregelt
legitimen grundlage verarbeitet werden
jede person hat das recht auskunft über
die sie betreffenden erhobenen daten zu
erhalten und die berichtigung der daten
zu erwirken wir sind jetzt zwei dinge
trainer es geht hier um das systemische
problem des wissens um die daten es
hilft meine autonomie schon sehr wenn
ich weiß was mit den daten gemacht wird
also wenn ich weiß warum diese daten
gerade diese tat und nicht diese daten
von mir jetzt weiter verarbeitet werden
das sind wichtige briefe
weiterverarbeitet wir wissen nicht wo
die daten am ende landen wir wissen
nicht was aus uns informationen die
gemacht wird und zwar deswegen nicht
weil wir hier zu bloßen gegenständen
eines instrumentellen interesses gemacht
wenn es zum hotel bedeutet jetzt sind
nur ein mittel zum zweck wir werden
reduziert auf informationen zur
generierung von
finanziellen dienstleistungen und aller
möglichen antrag das heißt wir müssen es
chemisch auskunft erhalten und wichtig
ist auch die berichtigung der daten
müssen wir erfüllen können hier ist
jetzt also ganz wichtige artikel 8 und
jetzt gibt es hier natürlich noch einen
weiteren satz die einhaltung dieser
vorschriften wird von einer unabhängigen
stelle überwacht es brauchte immer so
eine instanz die nicht
diese interessen einbezogen das klingt
natürlich alles ganz gut und aber auch
ein bisschen vage und jetzt haben wir
hier seit einigen jahren die datenschutz
grund verordnung die dsgv haben sie
bestimmt schon was davon gehört die
macht sich vor allem dann bemerkbar wenn
sie zum ersten mal auf eine neue
homepage klicken weil dann müssen sie
immer irgendwo unten oder rechts oben
oder wo auch immer so ein fenster
wegklicken meistens zumindest geht es
mir so lese ich das gar nicht durch es
nervt nicht nur und wenn ich das weg
gekriegt hab dann komme ich es zum
eigentlichen inhalt auch den ich ja
eigentlich nur möchte diese datenschutz
grund verordnung regelt eben oder macht
explizit was mit meinen daten geschieht
und ich kann eben hier wieder das hätte
autonomie wählen als ich kann ich jetzt
hinsetzen welche daten ich erlaube
dass sie weitergegeben und
weiterverarbeitet werden hier ist
natürlich auch wieder ganz interessant
was für daten sieht es die da auswählen
kann es geht um diese cookies also gegen
die auch auf meinem rechner gespeichert
werden häufig geht es um metadaten oder
eigentlich nur um mit der daten also die
frage von wo komme ich her von wo greife
ich zu mit welchem betriebssystem greife
ich zu solche daten die scheinbar
unbedeutend sind die aber in ihrer summe
ein interessantes profil ergeben und
rückschlüsse auf meine individualität
erlauben weil es so viele metadaten sind
und diese datenschutz kohlen verordnung
die hat jetzt hier in interessanten
artikel 4 nämlich begriffsbestimmung und
das wird jetzt schon ein bisschen
philosophisch weil wir fragen müssen was
bedeutet das alles alte personenbezogene
daten bedeuten nach dieser grund
verordnung tat alle informationen die
sich auf eine identifizierte oder
identifizierbare
natürliche person natürliche personen
sind wir zum beispiel wir lebendigen
wesen es gibt eine juristische personen
das sind ihr institutionen es geht also
natürlich um individuen folgenden
betroffene person beziehen als
identifizierbar wird eine natürliche
person angesehen die direkt oder
indirekt insbesondere mittels zuordnung
zu einer kennung wie einen namen zu
einer kennnummer
standortdaten zu einer online kennen
oder zu einem oder mehreren besonderen
merkmal die ausdruck der physischen
physiologischen genetischen psychischen
wirtschaftlichen kulturellen oder
sozialen identität dieser natürlichen
person sind identifiziert werde
also es geht hier eben darum dass ganz
verschiedene
formen der identität
offen gelegt werden können und ganz
kritisch ist natürlich auch genetische
genetisch walters besonders in unsere
individualität unsere biologische
individualität einteilige darauf gehen
wir noch später genauer ein profiling
auch sein wichtiger begriff bedeutet
jede art automatisierten verarbeitung
personenbezogener daten die darin
besteht dass diese personenbezogenen
daten verwendet werden um bestimmte
persönliche aspekte die sich auf eine
natürliche person beziehen zu bewerten
es geht auch um normativität was ist
wichtig dass es weniger wichtig
insbesondere um aspekte bezüglich
arbeitsleistung wirtschaftliche lage
gesundheit persönliche vorlieben
interessen
zuverlässigkeit verhalten aufenthaltsort
oder ortswechsel dieser natürlichen
person zu analysieren oder und das jetzt
entscheidend vorherzusagen wir kommen
noch mal einer sitzung ausführlicher auf
die bedeutung künstlicher intelligenz
aber war es künstliche intelligenz des
maschinellen lernens in thun kann
sprechen so an als ob sie ein akteur
wäre ist das auf basis ganz großer
datenmengen
profile und prognosen erstellt werden
können die ziemlich zutreffend also man
kann uns so kontrollieren durch diese
datenverarbeitung dass man nicht nur
alles weiß oder viel weiß was bisher der
fall war sondern auch was wahrscheinlich
der fall sein wird das heißt man blickt
in unsere zukunft von der wir selbst
nicht mal so gut wissen wie sie ungefähr
zahlen wird und das macht natürlich auch
unsere autonomie problematische wenn man
nicht nur in unsere vergangenheit blickt
sondern eben auch in unsere potentielle
zukunft das wäre glaube ich niemandem
von uns recht
und jetzt gibt es eben hier den artikel
6 rechtmäßigkeit der verarbeitung also
wann ist jetzt die verarbeitung der
daten rechtmäßig nur dann wenn
mindestens eine der nahestehende
bedingung nach stimmte die man erfüllt
ist die betroffene person hat ihre
einwilligung zur verarbeitung der sie
betreffenden personenbezogenen daten
verein oder mehrere bestimmte zwecke
gegeben das ist also ein punkt also wir
müssen die einwilligung geben und zwar
immer auf einen bestimmten zweck die
frage ist hier natürlich können wir die
einwilligung so ohne weiteres geben weil
die einwilligung voraussetzt dass wir
auch wissen was das alles bedeutet und
mittels der neuen technologien vor allem
künstliche intelligenz können wir
prinzipiell eigentlich gar nicht wissen
was da alles mit verbunden ist und das
ist ein riesenproblem also die
systemische autonomie die autonomie die
auch unser wissen anbelangt das klingt
alles so leicht als ob das absehbar wäre
was damit gemacht wird aber gerade durch
prognoseverfahren können wir es eben
nicht so leicht absehen weil es ja noch
alles wieder zukunft liegt und jetzt
möchte ich hier noch auf einen
interessanten fall eingehend es war auch
der wunsch dass wir darüber ein bisschen
diskutieren nämlich auf die frage nach
der rolle eines kindes also artikel 8
bedingungen für die einwilligung eines
kindes in bezug auf dienste der
informationsgesellschaft
also gilt artikel 6 absatz 1 buchstabe a
das hatten wir schon gesehen im
vorherigen bei einem angebot von dienst
der informationsgesellschaft
dass einem kind direkt gemacht wird
informationsgesellschaft ist auch
interessanter begriff so ist die
verarbeitung der personenbezogene daten
des kindes rechtmäßig wenn das kinder
sechzehnten lebensjahr voll in der tat
hat das kind noch nicht das 16
lebensjahr vollendet so ist diese
verarbeitung nur rechtmäßig sofern und
soweit diese einwilligung durch den
träger der elterlichen verantwortung für
das kind oder mit dessen zustimmung
erteilt wird also hier wird besonders
das wohl des kindes geschützt warum weil
man davon ausgeht dass ein kind noch
nicht diese autonomie besitzt um über
seine daten mit zu bestimmen und eben
deswegen besonders schützenswert geht ja
weil es eben auch noch eine gewisse
hilflosigkeit hat
eben dadurch besonders verletzlich und
schützenswert ist und somit eben auch
die eltern den eltern eine ganz wichtige
verantwortung zukommt mit blick auf das
kind natürlich kann man jetzt
weitergehende fragen darf überhaupt
dürfen überhaupt eltern es schon sollen
eltern darüber bestimmen dürfen
was mit den informationen des kindes
geschieht zumindest jetzt auch in
kommerziellen in sicht
sollte man vielleicht nicht noch hier
vorsichtiger sein und
vielleicht sogar gar nichts erlauben das
steht jetzt immer hier in einer spannung
eben auch mit der
informationsgesellschaft in einer form
in der wir uns bewegen müssen wir
irgendwie immer irgendwie über unsere
informationen bestimmen können also ein
völliges eine völlige unentschiedenheit
ist hier nicht möglich aber jedenfalls
ganz wichtig dass hier eben speziell
auch der fall eines kindes eines
autonomen
sonderfalls sage ich mal eben die
autonomie verhältnisse nicht so klar zu
tage treten dass die besonders ein
eingang wird in diesem artikel ja jetzt
möchte ich hier noch was diskutieren was
die privatsphäre im verhältnis von
analog und digital betrifft also wir
haben gesehen dass
digitale daten im gegensatz zu
analogen daten
zb einer physischen kartei reibungslos
identisch vervielfältigt und vernetzt
werden können ja also
denken sie mal zum beispiel an eine
zahnarztpraxis die eine große datei eine
kartei datei hat eine praxis aus den
fünfziger jahren müssen sich schon weit
zurückdenken es gibt sicherlich immer
noch praxen arztpraxen tvo auch so
karteikarten noch geführt werden mit
sicherheit ja
so wenn sie jetzt nur eine solche
physische karte haben
ja wie mit gehen sie dann zum beispiel
damit um wenn die praxis geschlossen
wird
ja was machen sie sie vernichten dass
wir nicht die kartei warum weil auf der
karte stehen nicht nur im namen adressen
sondern eben auch vielleicht
irgendwelche krankheiten oder ich will
jetzt nicht wissen wann person ihre
letzte wurzelbehandlung hat ja gut ist
jetzt nicht so schlimm aber es geht
niemanden was an ich kann daraus auf die
zahnhygiene dieser person schließen ich
kann vielleicht sogar anhand der
zahnhygiene
wenn ich dann irgendwie noch andere
verfahren darüber laufen was oder
psychologin psychologen zu rat wartet
sie noch andere dinge herausfinden auf
die ernährungsgewohnheiten schließen
also ich kann mit gewissen anderen
verfahren und algorithmen sehr viel
darüber hinaus erfahren über diese
person das heißt 50 er 60 ern vielleicht
immer noch heute wie geht man damit um
wenn die praxis altersbedingt aus
welchem grund auch immer geschlossen
wird man muss diese daten vernichten und
zwar sehr sehr zuverlässig das heißt da
gab es bestimmte spezielle
aktenvernichtung verfahren es gibt den
aktenvernichter wie dieses gerät so
schön heißt und wenn sie sich nur
aktenvernichter ich weiß gar nicht ob
das noch gibt bei mir im büro stand
immer ein aktenvernichter
diese akten vernichtet der ist meistens
auch ausgezeichnet als aktenvernichter
geräte müssen bestimmten standards
gehorchen
entsprechen damit sie überhaupt zulässig
sind weil wenn die spaghetti streifen
die in dieses papier geschnitten werden
wenn die zu breit sind dann wäre es
möglich diese daten wieder zu gewinnen
indem ich daneben puzzle spiele und sie
eben zusammenfinden sie musste irgendwie
ich kann mich nicht genau aus kann man
sich genau informationen irgendwann eine
größe erreicht werden ab der die
datenvernichtung als sicher gilt sie
sehen aber die datenvernichtung auf
physische weise ist gar nicht so leicht
verbrennen ist eine form der
datenvernichtung allerdings wissen sie
die kriminaltechnik hat da erstaunliche
fähigkeiten auch verbranntes wieder
sichtbar zu machen also wenn daten
einmal in die welt gesetzt sind und
dokumentiert sind erfasst sind dann
werden wir diese daten gar nicht mehr so
schnell los das möchte ich einfach
betonen also daten neigen dazu
irgendwie zu kleben daten neigen dazu
schlecht gelöst werden zu können das
sind wieder metaphorisch gesprochen
fußabdrücke fußabdrücke in sand im sand
der öffentlichkeit und setzten
dialogisch aussuchen die werden nicht
einfach durch eine welle weggespült sein
da bleibt mehr zurück
vielleicht bleiben noch metadaten zurück
also das ist eine sehr diffizile sache
daten souverän und wirklich zu löschen
und wenn jetzt habe ich das nur so
ausführlich dargestellt um einfach mal
zu zeigen wie es auf analogen auf
digitale weise und das ist ja das thema
uns asyl haus dafür kompliziert sich die
sache noch extrem einmal können sie
davon ausgehen dass wir jetzt analog
wird diese physische karte dass sie eine
digitale karte haben aber nur auf ihren
eigenen rechten auf ihrer festplatte
dann können sie natürlich rechtsklick
und der winde aus rechts beschlossen
dann geht diese dateien sagen wir
meisten word datei und excel datei
vielleicht besser wo sich alles drin
findet da geht dies excel-datei dieser
zahnarztpraxis die geht in den
papierkorb soll das erste ist natürlich
jetzt den papierkorb zu löschen viele
lassen es einfach überhaupt papierkorb
das wäre ganz analog sowie wenn sie ihre
kartei die sie haben einfach eine
papierkorb werfen da kann der
nächstbeste der an den papierkorb vorbei
geht sich eine karteikarte aus fischen
das heißt sie müssen natürlich den
papierkorb noch leeren jetzt ist
natürlich so wie sie bestimmt alle
wissen dass auch dann die dateien nicht
von ihrer festplatte verschwunden ist
also wenn sie bestimmte tools bestimmte
programme einsetzen können sie in der
regel sie selbst als laien anwender
sonst eben ein professionelles
unternehmen diese datei mit ziemlich
großer wahrscheinlichkeit wieder
herstellen das heißt auch die festplatte
ist in ihrer physikalischen struktur so
verfasst dass sich da irgendwelche
fußabdrücke festsetzen es ist gar nicht
so leicht ja was machen sie dann müssen
sie zu rabiaten methoden greifen dann
müssen sie den hammer nehmen im
wirklichen sinne und müssen je nachdem
um was für eine festplatte sich handelt
auch hier gibt es natürlich wieder
unterschiede müssen sie eben die daten
die festplatte physisch zerstören auf
den schreib kopf schlagen er aber auch
hier gibt es dann bestimmt noch
möglichkeiten das wieder herzustellen
sie sehen sie müssen eigentlich die
physische grundlage wirklich zerstören
und so eine festplatte zu zerstören ist
gar nicht so leicht wenn man jetzt mal
ganz extrem denn natürlich werden die
wenigsten versuchen ihre festplatte
werden sie da mal mit dem hammer drauf
geschlagen haben und sie wirken wie auf
dem sperrmüll landet dann wieder
herzustellen aber man weiß natürlich nie
das ist das problem also daten schafft
man nicht so leicht wieder aus dieser
welt wie sie in die welt auch die
digitale gekommen sind ist eine gewisse
us vertrieb und noch radikaler wird
dieses problem dann wenn sie die taten
nicht nur auf ihren individuellen
rechner auf der festplatte gespeichert
haben sondern wenn sie die daten im
internet haben zum beispiel der cloud
warum weil hier erstens in der cloud
immer mit der sicherungskopien erstellt
werden also spiegelungen vorgenommen
werden auf andere server sie wissen gar
nicht genau wo legt jetzt die daten die
datei weil ihr privat pc viren dieser
festplatte irgendwo da rechts im pc
drehen da ist die datei
oft in der cloud können sie den ort gar
nicht mehr wirklich identifizieren
machen sie vielleicht gar keine gedanken
oder wir machen uns keine gedanken wo
auf der welt sich der service das ist
auch in den spielt eine rolle wie da die
datenschutzvorschriften sind ist es in
deutschland ist es europa ist in den usa
ist es sind das ist eine wichtige frage
und selbst dann wenn sie die region
wissen wissen sie nicht woraufhin
welchem server zentrist ist und dann
wissen sie auch noch nicht wenn sie im
internet daten haben wie die daten
vernetzt sind also in welcher beziehung
zu anderen servern steht dass wer hat
sich das vielleicht schon immer gelacht
als sie im internet vor allem werden
daten nicht mehr wirklich lokalisierbar
das macht natürlich datenschutz nahezu
unmöglich und das lässt natürlich
verständlich machen dass hier stimmen
aufkommen die sagen wir sollten diese
idee vielleicht auch das ideal der
privacy der privatheit gänzlich aufgeben
weil es gar nicht anders geht ich möchte
dazu noch keine stellung nehme ich
möchte einfach nur dieses problem
darstellen diese erschwert den daten
schluss extrem wir hinterlassen im
internet fußabdrücke die unter umständen
dauerhaft bestand haben wenn sie mal ein
bild von sich in ihnen bekommen haben
auf unserer homepage haben dann mit
google bildersuche es ist schwer wieder
raus zu bekommen es geht schon sie
können google anschreiben aber es ist
nicht gleich künstliche intelligenz
hatte ich auch schon gesagt die
dynamisiert das problem des
datenschutzes durch algorithmen und
automatisierung der verarbeitung ihrer
daten
ja und jetzt müssen wir das verhältnis
von privatsphäre und internet noch etwas
diskutiert das internet steht in
gewissermaßen dem begriff der
privatsphäre entgegen dann ihm
prinzipiell alle daten reibungslos
geteilt und miteinander vernetzt werden
können
das internet ist gewissermaßen eine neue
form von öffentlichkeit und es lebt von
daten die miteinander sinnvoll verknüpft
und durch k analysiert werden
sofern wir das internet nur als ein
ökonomisches kulturmedium verstehen und
das machen eben die meisten nutzerin
nutzen sind wir in ihm schutzlos der
daten objektivierung ausgeliefert
wenige großunternehmen wie facebook
whatsapp alphabet twitter stellen
twitter wurde jetzt ja auch übernommen
wieder von einem anderen großunternehmen
stellen kostenlos zentrale infrastruktur
des internets zur verfügung sie sind
kostenlos zu googeln ist kostenlos auf
deren basis unsere daten dann aber zum
kommerziellen gut und kapital werden bei
facebook sind es auch personenbezogene
daten die dann für werbeanzeigen dienen
je nachdem welche beiträge wir lesen auf
facebook werden uns automatisiert
weitere werbungen eingeblendet also das
sind viele großunternehmen sie und
erlauben uns einerseits gewisse
virtuelle räume wie facebook auf der
anderen seite leben sie davon dass wir
in diesen räumen unsere fußabdrücke
hinterlassen er ist eigentlich eine
symbiotische beziehung aber sie ist
natürlich problematisch bei unsere
währung die wir da bezahlen die wird
nicht explizit
kommuniziert dieser deal den wir da
eingehend der ist uns häufig gar nicht
bewusst und wir bezahlen mit der währung
unser privatheit also wir bezahlen
eigentlich im geringen maße auch unsere
würde wenn man sitzt mal philosophisch
sie und die würde ist ein hohes gut und
eigentlich kein gegenstand des kommerzes
sollte man mal kritisch einen dh im
kommerziellen tat ich betone die
kommerzielles hat im kommerziellen
internet scheint datenschutz nur schwer
realisierbar zu sein sonst könnten wir
alle diese angebote gar nicht mehr gut
benutzen mit guten gewissen datenschutz
scheint im kommerziellen denn vielleicht
sogar zu widersprechen es gibt natürlich
jetzt verschiedene möglichkeiten dass
wir uns schützen können und das betrifft
das thema datenschutz um medienkompetenz
ich möchte noch mal betonen
medienkompetenz
sollten wir jetzt rahmen dieses seminar
sind auch grundsätzlich nicht nur
verstehen als technologische technische
anleitung wie mache ich das wie mache
ich das wie lange sollte ich vor dem
computer sitzen am tag wie lange sollte
ich ins internet gehen wie funktioniert
dieses gerät wie funktioniert dieses
programm das ist sicherlich eine form
von medienkompetenz aber wie mir scheint
noch die äußerlich sste die kern
medienkompetenz die wir haben und
entwickeln soll im szenario einer
digitalen bildung besteht darin dass wir
den umgang mit dem internet kritisch
reflektieren auch den umgang mit den
daten und dazu eben auch reflektieren
was ist überhaupt das internet und wie
können wir dahinter agieren das heißt
wir sind der objektivierung unserer
person zu daten nicht hilflos
ausgeliefert hier ist jetzt eine form
unserer initiative gefragt und zwar am
eigenen autonomie auch im sinne des
datenschutzes wir sind ja nicht nur
passive
opfer sage ich jetzt mal des internets
die nur vergeben kündigt werden sondern
wir sind frei wesen die selbst ob da
einiges in der hand haben das heißt es
hängt auch von uns ab die mit unseren
daten umgegangen wird man kann zum
beispiel das betrifft jetzt aber wieder
technische formen kann
anonymisiert ins internet gehen
pseudonymisiert das sind natürlich auch
der hoch interessante formen der
digitalen existenz der virtuellen
existenz aufgeben noch mehr eingeht man
kann seine herkunft verschleiern über
vpn dienste virtual private networks
also hier gibt es verschiedene
möglichkeiten ich möchte jetzt gar nicht
technisch diskutieren ich will einfach
nur dafür argumentieren dass wir ein
neues oder ein differenziertes
kritisches verständnis des internets
entwickeln soll also verstehen wir das
internet als ein passives konsumieren
und es machen eben die meisten der
nutzerinnen und nutzer immer noch dann
reduzieren wir uns selbst zu blusen da
also die autonomie die immer beschworen
die gilt natürlich in zwei halten
einerseits soll sie geschützt werden
durch andere andererseits müssen wir sie
auch selbst schützen also wir müssen
auch selbstverantwortung und bei unsere
daten unternehmen und nicht immer nur
auf andere deuten dass die unsere daten
schützen nein wir selbst sind gefragt
und wenn wir eben nicht das internet als
etwas anderes ansehen als ein konsum
video dann sind wir selbst auch
verantwortlich dafür dass wir uns zu
blusen daten reduzieren lassen verstehen
wir das internet hingegen als einen
öffentlichen handlungsraum indem wir als
freie autonome subjekte interagieren so
können wir uns ihm durch diese
interaktion nicht immer nur durch diese
passiven konsumhaltung
teilweise jedenfalls der für
gegenständlich und entziehen
in dem virtuellen handlungsraum des
internets wir werden auf das internet
als virtuellen handlungsraum noch
genauer eingehen sind wir mehr als bloße
vorliegende daten sondern virtuelle
akteurinnen und akteuren die entweder
pseudonym anonym auch mit klarnamen
interagieren die autonome ziel verfolgen
indem sie nicht nur daten bieten oder
daten darstellen oder das abgreifen sind
daten miteinander verbinde das scheint
mir ganz wichtig sein was machen wir mit
den damen aktiv da nicht nur abrufen
sondern in verbindung setzen das ist
ganz wichtig das heißt spuren im
internet sind nicht per se problematisch
sofern sie autonom reflektiert werden
wenn wir wissen was für spuren
hinterlassen wenn wir wissen in welchen
rahmenbedingungen diese spuren gelassen
werden und welchen zielen diese spuren
dienen wenn sie ökonomisch spuren sind
hinter denen wir gewissermaßen stehen
dann bekommt das problem des
datenschutzes eine ganz neue bedeutung
weil wir sie denn mal mit den daten dann
nicht mehr passiv ausgeliefert sind
sondern aktiv und über sich selbst der
hier ja das war jetzt eine sehr
umfassende einführung in das problem des
datenschutzes dass es sicherlich noch
nicht vollständig ich denke ich habe zur
anregung geben können die denn jetzt
auch hoffentlich als daten lage für eine
diskussion gelten können